- sexy formal and that's a good song
pretty good segment Starbucks open its
first location Italy tomorrow but back
in 1983 that country inspired former CEO
Howard Schultz to make the worldwide
coffee chain what it is today
Schultz made headlines in summer when he
announced he's stepping down as chairman
after 36 years with the company he joins
us from the new Starbucks reserve
roastery in Milan for his in Milan
rather in Milan for his final interview
representing Starbucks Howard Schultz
good morning to you I was in Milan last
summer but listen I saw the newspapers
from Milan this morning you are making
front page news Howard Schultz and this
is a 30 year dream come true for you you
said it's personal why Oh Buon Giorno it
literally is a dream it's a dream come
true as you said I walked the streets
here in 83 and to think I could come
back here after all these years and open
up the Roasterie in the heart of Milan
and the response people are banging on
the door to get in and we'll have this
big gala tonight and open up for the
doors tomorrow morning but this
literally is a milestone moment for the
company and for me but Howard you're in
Italy they know something about expresso
why would you think I want to take my
business there well you know as you know
we're coming here with great humility
and respect for the Italian culture but
we're opening not a coffee store but a
roaster e most Italians have never seen
coffee roasted and what we've created
really is the Willy Wonka of coffee
almost 30,000 square feet and it's a
labor of love the craftsmanship the
store we had a hundred Italian
journalists here yesterday and they were
in awe of what we've created and I think
we're gonna add something to the
Melanie's culture and values and I think
Starbucks is going to do very well here
I once had an Italian almost strangled
me for offering to serve him cappuccino
after breakfast what is it about the
Italian culture though that that makes
this pitch to them why you're going this
way well clearly
everything that we've learned over the
years is steeped into the what the
Italians referred to as a nectar of the
gods which is espresso and I think the
quality and the integrity of Starbucks
coffee freshly roasted in this facility
made by people who care so much about
customer service and the expression of
coffee and the passion and the love and
I think people are going to see that the
proof of everything is going to be in
the cup people are going to be surprised
at the quality of Starbucks coffee and I
think this environment well you know we
took over a building that is 200 years
old
it was empty we've restored it and it
really is a gift to the city of Milan
well Howard I keep thinking this is your
final act of your final store as
executive chairman of Starbucks and
you're going out with a caffeinated bang
but it raises the question what's next
for you are you considering politics
well I I kind of expected this question
Norah Soho you know what I've been
saying for the last few months is that I
took the summer off for the first time
in 40 years I've just finished writing a
very important book that I've handed
into Random House it'll come out in 19
I'm thinking about a lot of things I
said publicly that perhaps one of them
will be public office but there's a lot
of things I could do perhaps to help the
American people and help people who are
not being served by this administration
by not running for president we'll have
to see well back here at home there's a
lot of talk because someone from inside
the Trump administration has released an
op-ed essentially talking about being
part of a resistance even though there
are Trump political appointee but
specifically that this president is
amoral that he does not have out a
routing that defines his belief do you
think it's time that this country makes
a change well what I do think is that I
think the American people are somewhat
exhausted by some of the things that
have happened over the last year and a
half and I think people are longing not
only in the US but around the world I'm
in Italy and then I think it is a
worldwide desire for truth for civility
for decency and I think the world
is hungry for the idealism of America
and America's standing in the world so I
think this is a very important moment
for the country and I gave a talk last
night and I said we have to ask
ourselves what kind of country do we
want to live in what kind of world do we
want to live in and as citizens not only
as politicians as citizens and as
parents this is not a time for any of us
to be a bystander to be indifferent but
to make a difference and to be heard
well Howard you're certainly known for
speaking up we've seen the video from
Italy it really is a gorgeous space and
I heard that you started crying when you
walked in there and they were playing
Pavarotti you were crying tears whoa
you know I've waited a long time and
I've thought about this for so long and
this this is a fitting end to my career
at Starbucks and I've got great
aspirations for what I can do in the
future to try and help those people who
are being left behind okay we gotta go
we gotta go president Schultz we'll see
you when you get back to the u.s. and
looking forward to that book thank you
so much gradual on this store thanks
again our